Donald Trump has arrived in New York
City preparing to surrender for his uh
arraignment
and you know we got to with Charlie Kirk
is hanging out and we were talking
earlier so I think I think Charlie might
disagree but I I was saying this earlier
on my morning show that if you want to
explain to people just how close we are
to societal collapse or the precipice
just tell them ask them what happens if
Donald Trump doesn't surrender
34 counts what happens if Donald Trump
just says no okay well we know he's
going to New York he's no he's going to
do okay here's the other scenario what
happens if a judge says we remand Donald
Trump to the custody of the New York
criminal court system meaning he's going
to jail and they're not going to let him
out until the case is resolved
what do you think happens to this
country the front runner for the
Republican Party a former president for
the first time in history that's the
precipice because I could not imagine a
peaceful resolution if either of those
things occurs and that's what we're
dealing with right now and it's not just
the indictment in New York